all right everybody huge huge New York
City news on September 22nd your boy
will be doing Radio City Music Hall
folks in New York City tickets on sale
today at 10 A.M eastern time the
pre-sale tickets only pre-sale you have
to use the promo code Chrissy use the
promo code Chrissy
c-h-r-i-s-s-y Radio City on sale right
now pre-sale promo code Christy
September 22nd Radio City baby now if
you're not in the New York area you
don't want to travel I will be in
California this week uh Friday in Fresno
Saturday in San Jose Sunday in
Sacramento uh and also I'll be in
Vancouver tomorrow and then in March we
have Florida Fort Myers Orlando
Jacksonville uh West Palm Beach and
Miami March 24th 25th in Boston all four
shows at the Wilbur have sold out we
will be announcing a show in Medford
Massachusetts for the fall it might be
out there already so those tickets sold
out quick so if you want to see Chrissy
Boston's Chrissy Paul reveres
christycomedy.com for Ticky wikis and
then in April 1st we have Tampa Florida
April 12th Austin Texas April 13 San
Antonio so Ralph Barbosa fans come all
to that May 5th Buffalo May 6th Ithaca
May 7th Albany Mike Cannon will be with
me on those and May 28th Newport Rhode
Island but baby September 22nd Radio
City pre-sale code happening New York
City use the promo code Chrissy
it's a big one babe so I want to I want
you to come out for that big uh moment
for me and um I'm gonna shoot uh I'm
gonna shoot a little stinker out of a
T-shirt cannon what's up sexy chickens
coming up in March we got Niagara Falls
we got a big one at the Prudential
Center in Newark on March 10th March
11th at the dome in Wallingford
Connecticut March 12th Long Island where
you at Long Island Stand Up Man March
12th in Long Island the UBS Arena this
is basically our hometown show can't
wait to see you guys and then we got
Milwaukee Rosemont Seattle Portland
Boston and so on and so we we redid
Boston because the pipes broke yeah the
pipes broke April 29 back at the wing
and I think we're adding a show but
don't say nothing I told you
everything's on sale right now at
impracticaljokerslive.com I'll see you
guys on the road guys if you want to win
meet and greet tickets uh to see us on
the road on tour we do not sell them we
are not doing them the only way you
could win them is buy this contest I'm
about to tell you about right now every
single Thursday night at 10 o'clock
Eastern there are new episodes of
Impractical Jokers season 10 right now
all you got to do is take a picture of
you watching the episode it could be
with friends family or alone naked
eating a bowl of cereal will hashtag
jokerswatch party on any social you have
and every single week including tonight
and every Thursday we are going to pick
winners and give away tickets to the
tour and meet and greets it's the only
way you can get a meet and greet
tonight's episode is post Malone he's
the best check it out again every single
Thursday night at 10 on true ntbs
hashtag jokerswatch party I hope to meet
you and greet you on the road
[Music]
just the two of us we can make it if we
try just the two of us us and babe hey
babe how are you today how are you today
now let me let me tell you before we got
we have a great guest you've heard of
LBJ
okay you've heard of Lyndon Johnson you
mean you've heard of LBJ okay you've
heard of MJ you've heard of BJJ
Brazilian jiu-jitsu sure
but my favorite one of all
RWJ Roy Wood Jr folks oh there it is
has LeBron James taken LBJ from Lyndon
Bain Johnson he should right is it Bane
I don't know because I was about to say
I was about to say it I said Lyndon
Johnson because I was like what is the
middle imagine the B is for Bailey he's
like give me back your city
I I second term is mine yes I kill
Kennedy is it Linda Linden Lyndon Baines
Johnson imagine your middle name is Bane
listen I don't know did I mention I work
at The Daily Show I should probably know
this day yes do you yeah wait no you
work at The Daily Show eventually
[Laughter]
who are the powers that be really
seriously we want you to host it
honestly everyone wants you to host it
yeah you are beloved by everybody you
can't go Comedy Central let me just be
honest with you you guys haven't made a
good decision about five years the best
decision you can make is have RWJ the
real LBJ the peoples the people's Bane
host The Daily Show give me your show
yeah give me your show I don't know bro
I'm just happy to still have a job man
I'll be honest like I don't know what's
gonna happen like there's people like
you okay let me just keep being funny
and then the rest of this [__] will take
care of it did you ever meet a person
who didn't like you seriously I swear in
Christ I've known you by like forever
right [__] I swear to Christ I have
never ever and I mean this man you have
the the most pristine best reputation
out of anyone serious especially as a
person but as a comic I've never heard
look we're all we all are rooting for
each other we're all friends but
sometimes you hear people talk about
people they've been complain about this
that we Give opinions I have I'm telling
you right now I have never heard an ill
word about you about your comedy about
your character about your person from
any person across anywhere ever as a
comedian ever ever outside of women that
have dating relationships that I've
completely crashed that I should have
right I've tried but as I'm saying hey
babe [__] them hoes
you said
no but professionally I've heard some
like the even the stuff that people talk
[__] about me on it's so whatever like
I know that there are some comics in New
York City who did not like my second
hour special because they did not like
my outfit
yes uh what's that the hat that was the
one with the hat and the kids
it's the second one it's the second one
in Atlanta I wore I wore a white jogging
pants oh yeah yeah and apparently you're
not supposed to wear white jogging pants
with a white shirts yeah I don't know
here's some young Comics who are all
into their sneaker [__] or whatever so
if that shirt beef with me fine and then
there was a time where some snitch [__]
in L.A
there was a snitch [__]
in Los Angeles and if you're watching
and we know that you are go ahead
this snitch [__]
here's me do a bit
that the verbiage there was the same
word that came up in both bits okay
yeah but there was the same word in both
bits and shout out to the homie tone
Bill and so love tone they text tone
while I'm on stage Roy Virginia's doing
your bit
Oh I thought you were going to say you
had a word in your first special in a
bit they did they were like oh they're
kind of similar oh no it was just this
comic heard the word
and it started coming to me after the
show like a [__] adult and going hey
man I don't know if you meant to do it
like this but just so you know tone Bell
has a bit
that's all you have to do that's the
professional way to make a comedian or
worry if there's something that they're
flying close to somebody else's sure and
the word the yeah
so this snitch [__]
text tone Bell on some [__] hey man
Roy stealing your material now thank God
tone Bell and I know each other thank
God bill and I have Rapport yeah it's on
text me it goes what's the bit I send
them the audio because I record most of
the [__] new jokes there we go it's
nothing about like it's nothing and even
he acknowledged that was like
acknowledged there was nothing text the
snitch [__] back to let them know stand
down he's not a snitch [__] but to this
day tone Bill won't tell me who it was
oh
I don't know who it was oh but they know
it's been 10 years and you see my
emotions I don't know yeah you went out
to sell yeah tell them all right
it was us
and I'm sure
[Music]
I'm sure I've seen this person since
that time they're very friendly to you
hopefully they're decent person now and
it's fine it's a comic I get for sure
but I know tone didn't want to throw
that person to the Wolves because maybe
they were new and did yeah the game
right yeah that [__] yo that
gets into your skin but that but so that
is the only time that's the only person
though ever in comedy that I I've swear
to God I've never heard one person even
say even that to Roy even accuse him of
anything in a way dude it literally I I
don't I can't see I'm trying to think of
who
who is more like liked in the comedy
community than you dude I don't know I
mean I love you you're like one of my
close friends I I I don't always mean to
just give you a hand job George Wallace
is the only other one I don't always
mean to give you a [__] but it just
it's
the truth dude like this do you there's
no one really better than you dude I'm
gonna get a [__] from some of those
sounds that guy very soft hands for like
a guy who's in a you know like a
straight man soft his hands in a
straight male Community sound volcano
and by the way I think the guy who said
snitch [__] I think benatia may work
for him
everybody wow dish Bish yes yeah I try
to be kind can I ask you a question yeah
did you ever think to add like to get
someone to ask because I could I could I
could not even mention it I could try to
find out who it was
I I almost set up a sting operation
because the room that I did the joke in
was one of those Bizarro La house gigs
okay backyard with a [__] peacock or
a pit raccoon you know yeah yeah la has
a club scene and then there's the weird
Alti rooftop weird [__] so the comics
that frequent the weird [__] rooms for
the most part it's a lot of the same
guys yeah right so my thought was to
just go on stage take stock of every
comic in the room yeah do the bit again
and then wait for the text from tone
Bill and then at least I know yes
right and then the next show when one of
those eight or nine Comics is there do a
tone build bit verbatim oh right and
just process of eliminate that [__] all
the way down but the plan wasn't
completely foolproof and I have to like
let go of [__] like that because
especially when you get into like
comedy beefs
comedians other comedians they fan the
flames right and it's really it's really
[__] up I there was a guy
there was a guy who accused me of
stealing a bit
and this has only happened twice it was
the Tom belt thing but this was the only
time in 25 years where I was openly
challenged by another Community okay and
so he goes on Facebook he says what he's
got to say I assess both bids and both
bits to me it's a little bit more
parallel thought if anything the joke
premise was more lazy and we started
from the same place and dovetail into
different places okay we started at the
same premise you have a joke there and
then from there I went here and you went
over here but because we both started
here I've somehow stolen all of this too
right got it even though that's not the
truth yeah so yeah it's like when my
girl says oh if you lied about that what
else are you lying about it's like I'm
only lying about that
anything else you think I'm lying about
we're both just thinking of it it's
parallel yeah so
so he throws that up on Facebook and
this is the middle of the pandemic bro
and it's everybody's bored so yeah the
internet is split oh yeah fan in the
flames and before I can even put
together a reply I'm just going through
the comments I'm just reading to see
who's saying what and a lot of it was
comedians that I knew who know me and
know my pedigree and know how hard I
work at writing and they didn't even
give me the decency of a [__] heads
up to go hey bro just so you know this
is being said about you online right
they're in their [__] key keying and
laughing with these [__] who
know nothing about comedy you're in
there in the [__] comments laughing
with other [__] who are not
comics and don't know the code and don't
know the concept of parallel like how
dare you right how [__] dare you run
with me and be cool with me yeah and
then not even I ain't saying defend me
maybe I did steal the [__] but at least
I I've have I not earned the courtesy
[__] I put money in your pocket
right yeah right right I'm not talking
about some Comics I just yeah right then
right I broke bread with you right so
yeah I reply publicly which I shouldn't
have done yeah because there's a
different Power dynamic in it it got out
of hand and me and the comic got on the
phone and we had a [__] amazing
conversation oh and it was love deleted
both of our posts posted our call
to show that like you know blood [__]
truth yeah worked together did his
podcast a couple months later we talked
about it more on the podcast and all of
that [__] but to the street but to the
streets
all they'll remember is the first sure
sure that's it and so me going back and
forth with him publicly only invited
more idiots Into The Fray yeah because
people who are not comedians when it
comes to beef it's rap [__] where you're
just going to choose your person right
and so no matter what to those people
because I crossed their guy right right
it's [__] me for life right for life
it's such [__] and I'm fine with
that because I can be funny being funny
if it gives all sins whatever right yeah
but the comedians that were in those
comments I've not forgotten that that
[__] hurt those [__] betrayal and it
was a level of just breaking violation
of the code that I just don't [__]
Vibe it and I like you end up distancing
yourself from them without them even
knowing it or like yeah but I mean but
you know me bro I'm kind of a loner
anyway like I don't have a crew right
like I I have I know everybody say that
because you you seem like a guy you're
always alone but you're not lonely yeah
but that's why I just get the dip
whenever yeah yeah the downside to that
though is that creatively I think
sometimes I don't have the same
advantages of the comics have because I
don't have people that know me like a
right hand to write and create with okay
yeah
and do stuff with so that part of it is
kind of like yeah I wish I did would you
welcome that though
because you're always just you're always
aware with a pen and you know you're
always doing it you're always writing
new stuff yeah but the problem is that
you gotta remember though the first nine
years of stand up I was a road comic in
the South so you don't have clicks
you just with whoever the [__] you got
assigned to work with this week right
and then next week it's the next so
you're not yeah doing eight open mics
over the weekend with your buddies and
growing together and getting a slice in
between gigs it's just me and a 50 year
old alcoholic yeah yeah right right
staying out of La Quinta yeah [__]
watching the kids of a headliner who's
in the middle of a custody battle Yeah
right babysitting eight-year-olds you
started the road when you were still
living when you were still doing out of
college yeah I was in college Alabama I
was in Tallahassee at the time but okay
Birmingham still my home Club because
they had open mic more frequently than
Tallahassee but the idea of having a
comedy community as a road comic it's
just different so it's harder to have
those people so you just become kind of
a nomad so by the time I got to La I
just had my social habits were nomadic
like I can kick it with anybody I've
worked with everybody and right from
every demographic so I can hang right
anywhere which is dope like the thing
that I really respect about New York
Comics I think the thing that I
appreciate the most
is that
the comedians who don't necessarily
agree with my politics or the daily
shows politics still [__] with me as a
stand-up right and I think that's the
thing that I kind of really like
I don't know I think it's dope and I
have a lot of respect for those Comics
as well because I know that they don't
rock with everything politically at The
Showdown and that's fine but it's just
something about the comedy club that's
just it's [__] Switzerland I find
that to be true too it's like but I
think like that the public doesn't know
the comics are like that like whether
it's growing up in New York it's being a
comedian number one that's like a
Brotherhood and Sisterhood and I think
and baby hood and I think that the the
the
um growing up in New York it's very
difficult I always it's very difficult
to be like hateful in New York or hate
one thing because we're so in such close
proximity to each other that it's like
if you want to be racist go ahead or or
sexist go ahead but it's exhausting
because the people you hate you're gonna
see on the train the next stop you can't
separate yourself from that so you just
start to learn and become like well I
gotta I gotta Vibe with everything then
kind of thing it's just are you funny
yeah are you are you funny yeah that's
what it is if you get if you're funny
you get the respect oh yeah yeah like
like whoever opposes you know opposite
politics stuff exactly funny first funny
first always I think the con the younger
Comics are starting to make politics
their identity and that's the worst
thing you could ever do in comedy is
make politics your identity I don't even
try to correct young comics when I see
him doing that I feel like the industry
will correct them yeah because when you
look at like
all right if you look at television
television scripted television in my
opinion is a reflection of the beliefs
of a country
a year or two ago right where it's like
if you look at a lot of the shows that
are that are baked in with I'm saying
something specifically about an issue
and this show is about the issue all
right cool you got a good three-year run
after George Floyd we gave you a couple
seasons and now you're starting to see a
lot of pushback from networks where
they're going
um
I want a happy show
so as that starts as that tide turns
and the show's become less preachy than
I think the expectations that people
come to a comedy club they go you know I
don't want to hear that yeah yeah well
I'm just not gonna laugh at it I'm gonna
just sit quiet and the game is still
judged on laughs right I could clap [__]
being right that's cool but the game
right yeah is Therese said this [__]
shout out to there down in Philly he
said clever is cool funny is best
so this idea that
you can just run with your politics and
go there wrong I'm right all right
that's cool but sooner lady you gotta
have a joke and what you're doing is
working out because we're still in that
moment but
three to five years from now yeah you
can't hate your audience you got to give
even if you're doing politically you
have to tote the line you got to give a
little bit you got to be able to to to
to mock yourself yeah why would you
alienate a portion of your fan base
that's so stupid Daily Show as much as
it probably was a boon for you and your
career and everything do you ever see
any because it's related to like a
certain type of politics do you see
these did you see it like in any any
negativity from it or any way that it
might have hindered you I think the
issue that I run into now is that
fans of The Daily Show who come to see
me live find me to be a little more
Centrist sure than I am on the show sure
on certain issues and that matter of
fact
I'm going to show you a tweet that saved
in my drafts yes
that I started to reply to nice but you
learned from the other lesson never
reply publicly also this person the Stan
talked [__] to me publicly last week I
said nothing but I did book an
appearance on Legion of skank so you're
going to want to be there because I'm
going to rip the stand a new [__]
[__] but in person wait the stand the
stand basically I went on Legion I I
just did it for the first time like two
years yeah
Legion I was gonna uh say that I was
gonna do it they said oh who do you want
a legion of skanks and some of the fans
were like oh me right so I replied all
right give me a date whatever and then
the Stan said what's the point you're
just going to cancel LOL and then it
created like a whole bunch of things
whatever a whole bunch of things yeah he
said LOL though but then it's just going
to go and I'm just gonna yeah they were
they were just giving you a little yeah
yeah yeah so then but you say nothing I
had a whole thing written out same way
to take it now that's well let's see
we'll see when are you going on uh I
think March I'll tune in tune in all
right I'm wearing these glasses so there
it is but let's yeah I want to read Roy
draft here we go okay now that is the
tweet that was sent to me from someone
who came to the first show in San
Francisco and was not happy with the
joke okay okay so this is the Tweet
somebody tweeted Roy wood at Roy Wood Jr
your joke about Ukraine tonight dot dot
my Ukrainian friend came to your SF show
and the joke was upsetting I don't blame
your point but the idea Ukraine should
have less Aid because we have problems
here is difficult for those who have
lost friends Roy began to write back I'm
sure
this is between shows now this is why
you shouldn't check your phone between
shoes oh [__] no way
but what that tweet tells me is that
even the Twitter right there I'm like
that they're wrong but I'm doing
something that's touching the nerve and
that's good right that's what comedy
should do sure so trying to go back and
forth with the person I'm never going to
get them to understand what I was trying
to say because you've lost people in
Ukraine and also you ignored the whole
back side of the bit I used the base the
thesis of the joke was just the idea
that we send money for foreign aid for
any War send money for any war and if
you're from an impoverished Community
that's been down bad like I am when you
see other people getting foreign aid
it's like when you're in a restaurant
and someone comes after you and they get
their food first great that's the joke
great Point great joke so it's not and I
literally say in the bit I literally say
I'm not mad at you yeah I need to talk
to the waiter right so it's about a
conversation between Black America and
the government which is great but
that's not what I would normally get to
say on The Daily Show or would normally
figure out how the Nuance of it would be
more nuanced on The Daily Show but on
stage it's just man yeah all you heard
was the thing that made you feel the
thing well I think I have to respect
that right
yeah you have to be okay with getting
tweets like this honestly you can't
reply to everything no you can't and
then and I think what's happening too is
now because people throughout the last
few years have been you know kind of
getting ahead with like they feel like
being angry is almost like a currency
like if I'm angry if I stand up for this
and that then they feel like something
subconscious like oh I'll tweet that
that will help me get followers that
will help me because I'm tweeting and
saying something and usually it blows up
in their face but I think what's
happening now is look I've been doing
comedy what 12 years nobody's ever
walked out of my show and I say you know
on the line stuff last week at my show
people walked out a fam not a family a
group of people walked out for the first
time ever in my career because they said
I was transphobic but I think that they
just hear the word I have you know talk
to Jerry in my family it's just it's
trans red flag it's just to hear a word
all I said was all I said was TT Jerry
is is trans was in prison for 20 years
and I said I don't care if trans gay
straight you're in prison for 20 years I
feel like you're a Survivor and I want
you around me I said the safest I feel
all day is when I'm laying on Jerry's
tits and and they and they you know got
a good laugh and then they don't even
get where the train slammed the table
and then got up and walked out and I
finished my set you know didn't even
acknowledge them and then when I I was
about to leave and the manager of the
club was like don't leave yet they're
angry they're like waiting for you angry
so let us just get them out of here and
then I was like okay so got the matter
there and they were out there yeah I
know I wanted to yeah where are you
um no I I I I I I I I literally I was
like there that's what I said I said
that's not even transphobic what I said
I'm talking about a trans member in my
family who I lives with me who I've
taken in who I love and doing bits about
how much love we have and they heard the
word transgender heard a non-trans
person say anything about them and they
get triggered and they don't if they're
not even thinking it's like just
reaction everybody's reactive now yeah
and it's like but also within the Tweet
you know the person literally says I
don't blame your point period so right
there you understood what I was trying
to say so I have to concede that
everything else that I said might have
ticked you off because I'm hidden close
I'm flying close to yourself right and
that's just the game I think it's a
comic we can't police people's reactions
and I think that's where Comics are
starting to get into well why are you
it's just hey you like the joke I don't
know it's actually better that not
everybody likes us because that means
we're not hacks that means that at least
we're saying something if your jokes
gonna piss someone off that means it's
not General [__] and not everyone's
gonna like it if you're getting away
then you're just a road feature that's
doing the same set for 100 for 50 years
and you're going to drop dead of a heart
attack one day and elect we don't want
that to happen so we're like we're like
you know like specificity yeah because
you're right that's just what's gonna
happen dude you're gonna [__] you're
gonna drop dead one day at the Columbus
Funny Bone because you're doing the same
[__] you've made our career that's
supposed to be not a day job a day job
because you're doing the same and you
think that these jokes that are getting
laughs are are safe and good and that
that's being a comic's not about being
safe I gotta say you gotta say you know
I go up there I go up there on stage and
talk about how I think there's too many
Ukrainian Flags in the West Village like
this is the [__] America I'm like all
I see is Ukrainian flags and rainbow
Flags I feel like I'm in the gay part of
Kiev and people get upset yeah but it's
just I'm making a point because it's my
point of view I still like Ukraine but
I'm just like hey this is the US I want
to see as many U.S flags I think there's
I think there's a place for
for the comics who play it straight like
I think there's
there's an audience for it my issue is
just when people
when people are trying to
reshape what you say or what you feel
but then as a comic I have to you have
to you cannot reply you have to respect
this person came to a show and they just
didn't like one thing and for all I know
they might have liked the whole other 58
minutes of this year yeah so it's like
it's not even and then if you reply to
something publicly then you're inviting
everybody who did not come to that show
and has no context to create a narrative
right and that's what you don't want
yeah I just I cannot
I just cannot you know
I just don't want to exist in a world
where I'm not trying to push the
envelope but it's just difficult because
you know with
with liberal audiences sometimes what I
find is that the reprimand is about the
feelings right like like if okay like if
we go if let's go it's a hate mail right
let's talk hate mail where just straight
up I'll do a Daily Show segment and it
could be
oh again when I just did cop City we
went down to Atlanta they're building a
new police training facility at an
elevation that's going to [__] up the
environment down in the black
neighborhoods Downstream and it's like
ecologically it is a disaster fiscally
you could spend money on other things
whatever whatever right
so you have the pro cop people who are
just gonna go you're bringing race into
this and while you're bringing race and
the police and we love the police and
that's usually a two to three sentence
email you're a race baiter goodbye okay
fine
I get an email from somebody that's
quote on my side it's eight paragraphs
about how you didn't do enough and then
you need to do this and you need to do
this and the story didn't talk about
this and I'm like I have [__] four
minutes right I have four minutes to do
something and I'm sure we all want more
but also I have to have jokes yeah right
yeah I can't just stewing the sadness of
this [__] the whole time and that's the
challenge is trying to make jokes about
[__] that a lot of people ain't laughing
about so when you try to make it funny
I get chastised for not doing enough or
you make fun of them you're making fun
of them do you not understand satire
yeah yeah to be able to well that that's
why like for me I've made a choice just
like a life choice and it's helped me to
not respond or get affected in any way
shape or form by people who I don't know
who have opinions about me if I don't
know you personally if I'm not if you're
not my family or friend or if we're not
in the room together even if I just met
you I I don't let your opinion of me
influence me positively or negatively I
don't care if you think I'm the man I
don't care if you think I suck I I give
you zero time because I used to get
constantly sucked in and then you know
what a big thing is too the people who
do that who do get sucked in by it all
day they probably don't have kids they
probably don't have a family I realize
like yo I got three kids I can't do that
I could spend all day doing that so if I
now if you tweeted me or sound Tweeting
or a friend then I would take it to
heart and be like okay let me give you
some of my time what's going on here
because we know each other but if I
don't know you I'm like dude say
whatever you want about I don't care at
all it doesn't affect me the only thing
that bothers me we're all like
yeah YouTube oh yeah I can't explain it
I just can't explain it but YouTube
comments they are generally well thought
out well measured and a very fair
analysis of me as a performer oh this
[__] because you know what it is
on YouTube I think it's like you know a
tweet or whatever Instagram posts like a
little minute it's like oh it's just my
words but YouTube is like you watch me
for 25 minutes my whole being and you
were like that's not for me that hurts
we're like I'll take every part of you
get out of here what do you think about
upload because I'm I'm gonna do a
special in August and I'm I think I'm
going YouTube I think I'm gonna do it
myself and go YouTube It's the future
but um yeah it is but like it's like
it's the only platform where you can put
it up and then get comments right
underneath it about it for better for
worse good whatever like but like you
put it up on any other thing you know
what your views are you know how many
views you get but you don't know you're
not there's not a there's not people are
not commenting on it I mean did you
check that out on Netflix I like that I
didn't like it but like putting it up
there and it's like all right there's
gonna be 2 000 opinions on it right
underneath it and does that influence
people's opinions even if they don't
only watch a piece of it they don't
watch it or whatever it is and so it's
like that's an element that I think is
is a game changer on YouTube that is on
no other platform I wonder if that's a
better word not only that sound not only
to the comments and that and that's
that's for us and we cannot choose not
to look at that but the other part that
people don't talk about is based off
those comments and the algorithm in
YouTube if people don't like your stuff
and report it to YouTube it affects the
views negatively right where that can
happen and and you can yell I hate this
guy all you want at Netflix I'm still
going to pop up on your queue so let me
ask you a question if you're if you have
the ability to disable contact uh
comments to just say take this for what
it is I wanted to play just like it is
on Netflix do you get [__] on for
disable income I would imagine yeah
because you've opened it up to the
public now yeah so right you know when
you do a special on Netflix HBO it's not
open to the I mean it's open to the
public but it's kind of still like you
not everyone can say anything no one's
going to say anything to you about it I
think YouTube the only thing I'll say
about putting specials on YouTube and it
was a thing it was huge in the during
the pandemic and still you know big but
again it's an oversaturation where it's
like everybody does that now and that's
another thing that happens when you open
things to the public it just will kind
of make um the all it the Arts are not
for everybody well the thing is too the
haters can like you just said haters can
affect you without even watching this
[__] exactly right there's people that
love my show there's people that don't
like my show for whatever reason they
see that they go on they're like oh he
sucks this sucks he sucks they just they
don't watch it they just don't like me
already they have a preconceived notion
yeah and like you know it's kind of like
why do you want to open yourself up so
that's my only hesitation that doesn't
that doesn't bother me as much it's just
a matter of just not looking at it you
know which sounds crazy but it's not
like the only the only critiques I truly
respect and I truly take to heart is
email because my email address is not
public so if you found it you worked for
it like you really jumped around and you
found my personal email address just say
what you have to say to me I will reply
respect and nine times out of ten when
someone is saying something to me over
email it's usually something at a start
and it's a fair counter argument Point
analysis whatever which helps me become
more well-rounded and make the bit but
like even this Ukraine tweet helps me
okay how can I reword that in a way that
still says what I want to say but is
there a way uh yeah okay all right I I
at least I considered it and now back to
my regular [__] so I can at least say I
tried right what made me bulletproof for
the most part
was Last Comic Standing right bro 2010
Last Comic Standing that was the early
days of live tweeting and like the idea
of being able to talk in real time
to a performer on an actor or whatever
so NBC contractually made us engage with
the hashtag LCS oh sure and so for the
like we would take the show at five it
airs at eight so at eight o'clock you
have to be in front of a computer and
you just had to just retweet anything
you wanted or reply to anything but you
had to actively they had Hall monitors
watching the the hashtag so for a
[__] hour you're just reading the
worst [__] about you yeah mixed in with
nice [__] right but you have to read it
all every week for 10 [__] I made it
to the finals so I have every [__]
week and Monday for an hour I read the
worst [__] you get a two hour break then
the west coast feed goes up so you gotta
[__] do it again to the West Coast
and
just I don't know what I learned is that
most people just have all the same [__]
to say the critiques aren't thought out
yeah they're just yelling because they
get a chance to get it's riding on the
bathroom wall yeah well any any type of
anonymous any type of thing where you
can remain anonymous I think it brings
out the negative part of the human brain
where you're that these people who tweet
negatively at you out all of us probably
don't even feel that way about us in
reality but that's a different reality
there's two realities there's social
media and the metaverse as they call it
now and then our reality this reality so
I find that staying in this reality is
better you know we had Louis CK on the
Chrissy chaos podcast two weeks ago and
he said after all that stuff that he
went through everything that he went
through with his you know problems and
it was all on the internet mostly in
real life almost nobody said anything to
him ever it didn't it almost like it
didn't exist in one reality only existed
in the other and a lot of times we take
that other reality and bring it into
this but if you just abstain from that
and leave that reality where it's at
then then it doesn't affect you it just
doesn't affect you if you really you
know were in trouble then the law you
know in this reality then the law
affects you and then you get in trouble
fine but that reality and those people
I'm telling you those people who say
negative things to you probably come to
your shows it's almost positive they do
because they but they and also I think
what happens is
you always just say I'll [__] I
respond and then the person who said
some [__] about it was like yo big fan
bro yeah like I'm just once you know
it's like well here's another thing that
happens too it's like it's like you know
like when you are at Madison Square
Garden watching the Knicks and somebody
behind you is saying that a player on
either team sucks and you want to turn
around and be like the worst player on
that team if they had stage four cancer
in a wheelchair would beat you in a
one-on-one because they're in the NBA
and you're a fat [__] sitting in
section 305. same thing happens with
comedy we put our product out there we
have so many fans that we appreciate but
then they start to think they're as
funny as you they put in the work so
they start saying things just to be
funny but they they realize you're not
even if you say that you think I'm so
unfunny I'm still funnier than you could
ever be in your entire life because I've
gone to a level that I've we all have
that it's like so when people talk she's
the thing about it I think about that
that's the thing about comedy though is
like it's not it's just like the same
exact things where people think well
I've made someone laugh in my life yeah
so I I can tell you that you know yeah
it was funny that time yeah yeah right
yeah and they they have no idea what it
takes to do it they have no way and they
just think that they could be like you
know like oh this is [__] [__]
yeah so you'll watch my special back out
you know I I don't like this joke I
don't like that joke it's like try
standing up in front of strangers and
saying anything even remotely
interesting you can't right you would
you would literally be I mean you're
wearing Dockers I'm creating someone oh
you know creating someone in my head the
real high octane yeah nice doctors
non-wrinkle with a pleat can't be funny
I see that person the real high octane
comments if you really want to [__]
looking flaming hot Cheeto yeah your
self-esteem yeah Reddit
yeah and wait for this one Ticket Master
whoa
money yeah so they earned the right to
comment because they which I respect
ticket you paid for it I respect that I
[__] the head coach of the Utah Jazz
remember the heavy guy with the glasses
back in the day Frank something he was
like in the 80s before Salon before
before Sloan there was like I forgot
what his name was but he said there was
like this NBA video on VHS I used to
watch and somebody was heckling him and
he turned around he said did you pay for
those seats or did you get those from a
corporation he goes I paid the guy says
I pay everything goes and you could keep
heckling me I'm not hearing it from the
freebies but if you paid that's your
right and I was like oh [__] he said and
he let the guy [__] rip him a new
[__] because he paid his money so I I
respect the tickets they're [__] on
you any venue any venue that you all
have done that would Ticket Master
handled the tickets I've gone on there
you can go back and read this [__] yeah
a lot of what I see on those though for
the most part but knock on wood is like
not Performance Based it's more like you
know like the [__] we couldn't hear
you know like that yeah they complain
about like this situation and stuff it's
shorter to take a master comment to not
YouTube like there's like three
sentences in a star yeah yeah yeah in
and out but Reddit those [__]
have like it's a forum they have a
conversation that's years long on that
it's crazy
rocket money canceling all your
subscriptions rocket Money Baby formerly
known as true Bill yes okay rocket money
it's a personal finance app that finds
and cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place this
is the type of canceling you want to do
if you're going to get canceled get
canceled by Rockets this is it try free
for 30 days there's enough time to try
and completely forget about a
subscription to this service I do it all
the time I say it I use it yeah it
worked for me I saved about 270 bucks
yes rocket money is good so stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
hey babe that's rocketmoney.com hey babe
rocketmoney.com hey babe you're gonna
love it over three million people have
used rocket money saved them 720 a year
so 80 of the people that have
subscriptions they forget about eighty
percent why are you hitting that 10
people because I'm so excited what it is
if you guys are listening to this I'm
punching Chris right now I love it
rocket Money Baby quickly and easily
identify your subscriptions and change
your life I love it the Rocket Man
all right here we go hello freshness my
old friend America's number one meal
King
sending fresh and greedy ants for me
I cook it in 20 minutes or so so I eat
all the meals with my family and it's
healthy and the options are Way Beyond
Fast and Fresh recipes
hellofresh taste and quality
ingredients and seasonal recipes yes
leave it right to your dough step skip
strips to the grocery stove and count on
hello fresh to make home cooking easy
fun and affordable that's why it's
America's number one meal kit yes I love
it you're gonna find quality ingredients
and hellofrescious recipes in fact the
ingredients travel from the farm to your
home in less than seven days so you know
they fresh remember those New Year's
goals you promise yourself you can stick
to yep hello fresh is here to help you
eat better by delivering fresh
ingredients and easy recipes taking the
hassle out of dinner time that's it baby
and if you're looking for an easy easy
way to eat well and save money cut back
on expensive takeout and delivery and
get started with hellofresh you'll love
how fast easy and affordable it is to
whip up a restaurant Quality Meat right
in your own kitchen that's what they say
about salad and I we're fast easy and
affordable that's right
um go to hellofresh.com hey babe65 and
use the code hey babe 65 for 65 off plus
free shipping Sal tell me how this
company makes money I I don't know it's
a crazy last time I was at your house
you had two uh brown bags of uh yeah
hello fresh right on the table I said oh
my God yeah you practice what you preach
I have so much hella fresh in my house I
mean for my birthday I'm popping out a
hell of fresh boxes for people's
birthdays left and right that's what it
is it's amazing hellofresh.com hey
babe65 use the code hey babe 65 65 off
65 off plus free shipping hellofresh
America's number one meal kit
I think too I know like we you know I
think sometimes too with Society like
things are I understand there's problems
I get it but things are so good in in
life like we have so many things that
are just so we have the best health care
we have the food we have every basic
need met every basic need met even if
you're living in the slums of the slums
in America pretty much your primary
basic needs are Mets or what has to
happen then is your brain has to create
problems for survival so then in an
effort to survive people have everything
they want they're like I gotta think of
something to make me mad it's like a
motivating factor and that's a lot of
times what the internet is these people
are just like well it's an outlet it's
an outlet and I don't even really hate
my car his or her comedy that much but
I'm just gonna I'm gonna I gotta say
something type of thing and that's how I
look at it I almost feel like if you're
commenting like now I feel like if you
comment negative on something you gotta
understand the type of pain that human
being must be in because dude I've never
commented to negatively on anything in
my life because I'm like if it bothers
me I just move on because I'm happy he's
taking the time to sit you have to
you're dealing with an individual that's
hurt that's got that's in pain
and that's where like when you start
getting into like the conversation
around like mass shootings and [__] I'm
like okay these are the [__]
that are taking the pain off the
computer out into the real world right
right we're like okay I'm mad about some
[__] and then I had the confirmation
bias conversation or whatever Echo
chamber right Reddit chat 4chan dark web
[__] that I that I frequent and then I'm
going out into the real world and
everybody's like whoa what the [__] is
your problem bro why are you right right
right where are you out here Barefoot
with a [__] bazooka right yeah yeah
you could have yeah calm down there was
other places on the internet you could
have gone yeah you've gotten some
[__] help man that's the [__] that I
really like when you look at mental
health too that I don't think anybody
talks about it's like this idea that
check on your friends right right okay
absolutely check on your friends but
they never tell us how
right like we've been just like the
healthcare industry is like deputized
every regular person into you evaluate
your friends psychosis and make sure
that they're and if not call you see
something say something yeah okay you've
got to help yeah you can you go to
betterhelp.com put in that promo code
hey babe 10 off the first month yeah I
just really wish that there was more of
a conversation about the ways that we
could talk to people and engage them
because like whoever is the guy that's
listening to Echo chamber hate [__]
right it's got the guns there's a friend
there's at least somebody that could
intervene yeah and just hey man I ain't
seen yeah a couple days right right
right right right right but how to have
that conversation in a way that's
effective I don't think we've ever
talked I mean look Society a couple of
weeks ago with the Super Bowl all the
commercials 50 of them were were
medicine was just like medicine ads and
pills to take when it's like a lot of
the times man it's like you don't need
all that like you don't like my daughter
right what doc you know take a picture
nutrition you know we just met you like
oh she's a little hyper in school to
teach such a little hyper in school so
right away doctor condition meds and I
said no no I wanted to get from you is
there a website is there a game that we
is there a way like because no I'm not
I'm not fidget toys not giving her meds
what are you talking about like she's
seven right but that's what these
doctors are conditioned to think and the
byproduct of a lot of that a lot of
those side effects a lot of those
medicines people are on man it gets
isolating and then you know the internet
I'm telling you I think that the
internet in 50 years will be looked at
or social media specifically will be
looked at the way people look at
cigarettes where it's like hey remember
remember when there used to be messages
about it because now or already now it's
starting to happen uh Neil Brennan sent
me a New York Times article about
there's a girl out there now who's 16
years old who's trying to you know kind
of uh be the champion of of people that
say if you're my age 16 get off your
cell phone get all get social media
detox get out of it get off you YouTube
get off because they're seeing what it
did to the old their parents who are
like my age 38 40 and they're seeing
like there's a lot of problems with it
so I think that where I think we're
living in a time where I don't know what
it's going to become but I know that I
could see myself I told you I got off I
got off the internet August 26th it's
only February I lost 30 pounds
everything in my life changed my whole
outlook on life change relationships
improved you know everything because I
got all that negativity just out of my
head and now Venetia deals with it
Infinity has gained 100 pounds and is
suicidal but uh it's about pushing me
forward
that's what happened do you feel like
there's anything you you touch whatever
you want you touch whatever you want I
have to touch everything yeah not women
without their consent I I have a thing
where like a part of my family I'm I'm
uh I'm educating get trying to get new
fans that don't you know that don't know
that I don't like I'm a stand-up but
then a lot of my fan base feel like they
know me very familiar especially with my
show and so sometimes they'll come and
like if I deviate from what they expect
from me right I feel I see it hear it
feel it right away right so it's like if
I want to talk about it and I do I'll
still talk about it anyway but it's like
I see it tighten up right away and I'm
just like
does it pay for me to invest time in
this type of material where I'm going
against this grain or should I just kind
of ride the wave you know what I mean I
think ultimately if we listen to the
audience and we become the audience so I
just think you do whatever that if if
they had if they hate let them hate how
do you how do you order your act like
the bading order of your act in terms of
what you want to do versus what they
want to hear
I mean right now it's it's mostly like
if I'm I'm a Storyteller it's more
observation a little more Evergreen for
me like it's more like that but like
then if I get an idea a premise I like
it whatever I'll still write I'll still
throw it in there I'll just look for the
right spot to throw it in but I'm I'm
primarily kind of Storytelling and and
more like I said but like I'll do
something like stupid like um
like I'll be coming off like some like
you know nothing edgy and then I'll just
be like let me I'll be like let me
change the let me change the mood the
death penalty or something like that and
then everyone like like gets shot but
then they tighten right yeah is it like
they're like we're gonna listen to him
don't let him talk about the Death
Valley now you know what it is part of
it is that Impractical Jokers as a brand
is Escapist
humor in the sense that that show gives
people a moment to breathe away from all
of the things and that's what we love
about we lean into that I love that but
then I show up to see you right and then
you lean into one of the things I'm like
yeah but then I don't right so then they
think I'm gonna but I don't but then
it's like what you said they just hear
the words like I'll be like the death
penalty I was like like I let's talk
about it right so I said like something
like uh I I don't really have a problem
with like uh you know it's it's not it's
not it's not about like do we have the
right to play God you know do we have
the right to take a life you know what I
mean I I say I have more of a problem
with the last meal right so so now
they're like it's just it's silly again
you got silly again but they're also
like what the [__] and I'm like I'm like
we could agree that on paper it's a
murder this is a murder that's about to
happen on paper why are we catering
right so then so yeah whatever there's
still nowhere you know what I mean and
it's like it's like and the fact that we
get them anything they want right is a
weird caveat it makes us feel like we
feel guilty right you know like we're
about to put you down in front of these
people for what you did but we're not
Savages so if you like it by tanash
whatever you want we'll get it for you
you know what I mean but people just
heal death penalty still right and I'm
like there were times I was like there
were times at the dinner table my mom
was like you're gonna you're gonna [__]
around like that go upstairs and I was
like I didn't get dinner just for
horseplay at the table this guy mows
down a half a dozen people on a
Santander Bank we owe him pumpkin
ravioli and like but they still they
still don't want that from me but here's
the thing though I think that you're
better off leaning into what you want to
be an evolving because if you're not
careful then you you
[__] I can't name his name but like I've
opened for guys on the road that are in
the prison of just being what the
audience wants yeah and now it's too
late because yeah that's right yeah look
at Bob Saget he did Family Matters
people come I'm sorry um uh uh Full
House Full House and then and then and
then he's [__] dirty as [__] yeah and
then people would come and they're
probably mortified but he still had this
whole stand-up career post Full House
Rob Saget walked out one night
opening joke
I knew back then the Olsen twins were
gonna be hot yeah
opening
they were five night not even good
evening how you're doing yeah oh first
words out of his mouth Yes [__] I
knew back then the Olsen twins were
gonna be hot
what the [__] bob jacket said on an
interview right there you level
everything Bob sockets that are
interviewed literally it would be the
APM showing a Saturday 50 of the room
were little kids families thinking that
it's Danny Tanner Full House and he
would come out and be like I want to
[__] the Olsen twins yeah
yeah and so so I think I tried to
address that too because we had kids
yeah it's 16 plus but these families
come they bring kids I pull a little kid
on stage immediately at the top and I
just I just feel like he's gonna be hot
one day
no no but but but I think Roy's 100
right I think anything in life forget
about comedy just obviously you know
like you've heard it a million times
just be whoever it is you want to be
because because people are gonna not
like you anyway no ma you're not going
to get through this life with P
everybody liking you and if everybody
likes you you're a people pleaser that's
not good at all you don't want that you
want to fundamentally be who you want to
be you know within reason not hurting
people or whatever but and then
ultimately I think that's the best right
I mean that's the then you'll feel good
about yourself I'm like well I'm
unapologetically me like lizzo be the
lizzo be listed go out there and be
lizzo everybody yeah that's what I try
to do every day yes
I'm the lizzo of Comedy
oh
yeah
um yeah but I don't know dude with that
being said if you don't use Roy wood as
host of The Daily Show then I'm going to
stop I'm gonna
no you got it now there you go
unleash my inner Intel I uh yeah I don't
know dude I feel like but I will say
even like Tides turn right because like
I remember there was a point in my life
where I didn't like Bill Maher I just
was like yeah whatever but now I love
Bill Maher because what has Bill Maher
has done the thing that he did is for
the past 20 plus years he's always just
been himself he never wavered if he
would have be tried to become you know
what I wanted him to become 10 years ago
I probably wouldn't like him now because
but there was like oh like you can sense
like a phonies but he never did that he
was like I don't give and then all the
people who disliked him we've all come
around now and like him again because
he's just because the thing is he's just
it's got nothing to do with what side
you vote for right I don't give a [__]
about that it's just this [__]
believes in what he says and stands by
what he says no matter how much Flack
he's getting that's what I respect
people who don't change like that they
have it uh I think we all agree Bill
Moore should be the new host of The
Daily Show then okay well 100
CNN's got their claws in him now
CNN's got their claws in them now yeah
oh really they're running reruns of Bill
Maher on cna's trying to get into comedy
space now really oh yeah Roseanne's got
a special coming out on Fox News yeah
like what this yeah everybody special is
coming out yeah yeah yeah like it's a
gut fold uh Gutfeld comedy show yeah
dude some of that [__] they be seeing on
gut feel be funny I watched that [__] it
is I'm gonna tell you straight up yeah
I'm not gonna sit here and like I don't
watch all the things I've been watching
all that [__] also a lot of New York
comments I know right on gut field so
it's like I want to see what the [__] my
buddy is also going on gut film Joe
DeRosa went on a a month or two ago said
he for the only time he's been on
television in a late night format where
he's actually gotten followers and
ticket sales from that was good though
because so many yeah you got got felt
when they say on Fox News and this is
not an ad for Fox News but when they say
Gutfeld is the number one show in late
night that's a fact they get more views
than Jimmy Fallon everybody
huh
and you don't have to go on there and be
he has people on there that are not
right wing Comics I mean Joseph Joe's in
the middle you know or to the left even
the idea that
so this idea that comedy could only come
from HBO or the late night network shows
so the idea of YouTube and all of that
[__] or like daily wire is doing
stand-up specials now yeah Fox Nation so
it's like
kind of thing that same [__] that you've
heard all get him where you fit all this
[__] is just every channel every
streamer is just a conduit to convince
strangers to see you live yeah correct
all of this Chris Rock said that
everything I do is just get people to
buy a ticket tickets that's that's how I
feel it's all to buy tickets and Bill
Cosby said you know one a good quote he
had Bill Cosby he said he said I don't
know the secret to success but I know
the secret to failure is trying to
please everybody and I remember reading
that years ago being like that's some
[__] right there because if you're
trying to please everybody there's
you're one thousand percent gonna fail
because that's an impossibility so when
you have now let's say in comedy you
know okay if the networks don't [__]
with you but yeah I mean dude look at
look at some some of the biggest comics
in the world right now they you know
they wouldn't uh they they wouldn't Tim
till and they they wouldn't get and you
know or neighbors
napargazi's not up there you know saying
things all the way to the left not at
all he's in the middle maybe to the
right man their careers are
The Improv forced
strategic improvisation forced by being
rejected by the mainstream yeah like
when you look at Andrew Schultz and what
he's a good example the whole [__]
Empire of what he's built over there
yeah like that's because that was after
hundreds of no's oh yeah and then he
[__] hit him with the Pedro Serrano
Major League I say [__] you Joe boo I'll
do it myself that's it baby
I quoted that last week I say [__] you
Joe Boo and do it myself yeah yeah but
yeah like those guys man they've shown
that
the idea that you can only do it one way
it's false yeah it's false and like once
you get people out to see you live then
they'll deserve because here's the thing
like if you if you went up and you were
trying to tell
cue immersed stories for 20 minutes then
merge into your [__] then it's some
halfway type [__] where somebody knew
who's just curious about you goes oh wow
there's a different side to him I just
thought he was oh yeah I don't even
mention a word about anything about that
that's this is the whole point right
it's putting space between it yeah yeah
perfect because then you get the new
people that come out and see you yeah
and then they'll bring more people and
more people right right yeah that's all
that that's all it is it really is like
comedy is still in our form that's word
of mouth and best consume live in a
smaller intimate space you know when you
get you know when Louis was on he said
you know what the one thing he realized
about doing Arenas is you're not
supposed to be doing that for too long
and you're not supposed to be up there
he was like you know I was doing the TD
guard in the Boston Garden saying man I
should have just done two or three at
the Wang because it was so much smaller
because you just start to then you
realize like [__] I'm just doing this
for the money now and the fame and
that's not what comedy is music is that
way consumed by a hundred thousand
people but comedies there's an intimacy
there that you need to remain for as
long as possible for it to be like a
good effective show and I think they
could smell the [__] that's why like
you know when you have certain Comics
get to a certain level and the specials
are you know pyrotechnics and they got
jets flying over it's like you've lost
that you're supposed to be the everyday
man comics were supposed to be like hey
we're identifying with everybody kind of
thing you know it's not supposed like
people like oh Rockstar like there was
that Super Bowl commercial oh
so-and-so's a rock star remember that
remember the Super Bowl commercial it
was um it was just on it was like people
working in the office they were like
you're a rock star and it was like Kiss
you'd be like you're not a rock star
coming in yes I think it's the same with
comedy we're not rock stars right that's
not what we are rock stars are rock
stars we're comedians so it's a
different thing I think even the guys
that got to that plane like
Eddie Dice Clay Kevin Hart Steve Martin
Steve Martin yeah Kevin Hart definitely
Dane Cook I would argue thank you albums
yeah for the yeah first two episodes
Circle and yeah
um retaliation oh retaliation
retaliation and then vicious Services
yeah yeah yeah like rock star but then
he came back I think it was his third
special he did it at the Laugh Factory
and he brought it back to the intimate
[__] like you can't fly at that yeah
forever like you have to at some point
get reconnected yeah I
I don't know man if I had a chance to do
Arena I'd [__] go get that money
though oh yeah yeah are y'all are y'all
scared of the AI
oh yeah have you thought here's here's
what I'll as a father now let me put on
my father hat to the fellow fathers here
right
have you thought about the ways that
your industry could be [__] by
technology in a job that you once
thought was [__] safe into perpetuity
is now on the brink of Extinction and
are you [__] scared of that [__] I
haven't talked about that last night for
about an hour yes yes I swear to God I'm
scared of it from scripted like writing
[__] ai's gonna write TV shows and we're
gonna be [__] once it learns our
algorithm and thoughts and all that [__]
but I still think the live show we will
revert back to that yep even if it
becomes this Boutique underground yeah
[__] thing well there's got to be
that kind of Correction right already
Howie Mandel is reading his podcast ads
on AI already that's happening already
break down how he does not Howie Mandel
does not read his podcast ads his AI
version of himself reads his podcast
with the voice with the voice and his
face yeah he has the money for the New
Age Technology but that technology once
it is Affordable to us that's what he
doesn't do it he just does his show and
then his voice like some E-Trade Baby
Lip add executing no he had to only
allegedly film it once and then he's
people just type in what that AI Howie
Mandel needs to say and the ads for
hello fresh and everything else is done
and and it is over so the AI ads are
already here as far as now the next I
mean look at that Joe Rogan podcast
there's a whole three and a half hour
Joe Rogan podcast is 100 AI it is one no
right pimpy I'm not wrong on that right
yeah there's a hunt Google Joe Rogan AI
podcast
you think it's actually pimp this is an
AI I only found out about this thing
where they're writing for you like my my
writer said as a joke they ran it
through the they ran our show through
the thing and so if they can come up
with some ideas for the show and they
said they were like simple they weren't
good but they still they still they
still think it'll get generated ideas
for our shows get better and you think a
network isn't going to cut costs with
that especially with us strike coming up
and they're gonna [__] have to pitch
up more of the the um streaming money
right yeah and eventually it'll be a
counter there's always a counter after a
strike yeah there'll be an AI actor that
well just Mom we're a year away from the
first all AI Movie that that still
you're gonna have to pay for the
likeness of Tom Cruise but he's not
gonna have to do the work you know
things like that that that's what's
gonna am I wrong about that
20 minute sorry so 20 minutes not the
job Steve Jobs so Rogan interviewed
Steve Jobs all AI who's AI Rogan Rogan
is the AI and Steve Jobs you cannot
right if you pull it up you you cannot
tell the difference and they're both
having a conversation they're having a
full conversation everything is the same
because as it's real it's freaking and
the other part about that is okay so
we'll probably will everyone in this
room will most likely be safe because
we've learned a skill and as you said
the live performance will be there
pimpstrom will be there venetia's job
will be there we'll probably be okay but
our kids exactly that's what that's the
scary part where now are my daughters
growing up in a world where almost all
and then what do the people who aren't
as fortunate as us what do they do
there's going to be no room for everyone
I'm starting to think that a lot of this
[__] like some of these natural
disasters and stuff like you could
[__] make an earthquake you know the
government's like we got too many all
the governments of the world are like we
got too many people we got to start disc
getting some of these people off here
and disguising the [__] as natural
disasters disguising it as War but it's
really like we need to because every 30
years dude what do you think World War
II was World War II was 400 million
people off the planet in four years
that's a that is a reset and people
don't you know you think it was war and
Hitler and this and that and it was but
it's like there's parts of me now as I'm
going through life being like do the
powers that be just be like well we can
use a virus we can use a war we can use
a natural disaster about the pandemic
yeah you heard that it's like right I
think of America as a corporation I
don't necessarily think that the world
is a global Corporation or if it is it's
multiple corporations that aren't
necessarily on the same page but either
way every now and then a little bit of a
reset a little bit of math yeah that
might be good for the corporation
because you can keep a little fear there
keep the control I just when I think
about
Ai and all of that [__] as it relates to
my child I'm like
oh you can be a pilot probably won't hey
I'll do that [__]
um we we probably once they once they
figure out the autopilot on these cars I
forget AI autopilot already lands and
takes off planes yeah
so it's not really that big of a
difference the Pilot's just there
checking on [__] mid-flight right yeah
that's true they don't really fly the
plane at all really not really so then
you'll have some pilot stewardess hybrid
yeah the plane shakes and then the
flight excuse me a second I gotta go
check on the stairs the AI students are
still horny
yeah I
I worry about
I think entertainment is always the last
one to surrender to technology
you know there is the argument to lean
into it in creating better written
content I guess right
I don't know man well in a way we
already have had to kind of surrender
small way to technology with the
algorithm you're not going to get
anywhere with ticket sales unless the
algorithm deems itself right the
algorithm has to say Let me show your
stuff to Millions more people because
millions of people already liking it and
then the ticket sales come or the
algorithm you know will say will will
show that you're popping up in the city
if you pay it to do that if you pay the
IG algorithm your ad money if you give
it your money it pops up in the city on
your phone if you don't then you don't
get tickets so in a way it's happened
already you know how much of it you want
to give up is is up to you but I also
think though that like
so many times in history we've been here
before not as not this specific issue
but it's like you know when the printing
press came
everybody's job got wiped out you know
because there there's no and then you
just kind of adapt to the new thing what
the new thing adapting
to what to adapt to is I don't know I
guess that's the game figuring out what
are you going to adapt to but as far as
like this fear of this is oh [__] we're
on the precipice of of This Disaster I
kind of feel like we've been here so
many times yeah but I think
exponentially it's speeding up but I
think that somebody in 1500s would say
would have said that it's not fair
that's fair but then the question
becomes as a parent your job is to
predict the curve and prepare your kids
for a world that you can't even conceive
got it so what the [__] world are we
conceiving when the curve is fast
because my mom you know the curveball is
a festival I'd fast curve yeah faster
I guess the sink was just a faster
like the idea that my parents would just
get a college degree and pick a field
and so journalism is what I gravity I
got a bunch of journalists in my family
so that's what I ended up in but by the
time I got out of college
half the jobs in The Newsroom were ought
to be half the cameras in the [__]
room aren't even [__] manned anymore
and the person that's controlling them
isn't even in that [__] City then
when I started doing radio half the
radio jocks that you hear between songs
they're not in town so if they're not in
town now you don't even need to pay a
job just use the goddamn Howie Mandel
[__] yeah and just type in the words you
want the machine to say yeah that was
the hot new track from cardi B coming up
next so I'm [__] brand new Amigos
like yeah right right and as it gets
better it'll sound blacker
yeah the only encouraging news that I've
seen let's let's end with something
encouraging the only thing one thing one
thing just before you you were waxing
and you went like this with your glasses
which you've never been able to do
before which is and it was a whole new
thing so there's a new Christmas yeah uh
this is AI this is what my AI looks like
yeah this one so so one news article I
saw which I was like okay that's good is
you know everybody during the pandemic
of course are saying that you can work
from home now what's going to happen to
the say skyscrapers in any Downtown City
or whatever that uh that they're getting
the same work rate from the from the
from people at home than they would be
in the office so this company's not
going to spend the fifty thousand
dollars to rent the floor right all that
was true the stats from the last three
months have seen a decline in work from
home because people were social beings
and we want to be back in the office
with each other and we'll work better
human than we will with the with the AI
doing everything so the trend could be
trending now the other way so some
companies are taking that research and
being like Oh the social aspect of being
human is the thing that AI will never be
able to do and Conquer and that might be
the place where all the jobs are at I
think what we what we're approaching uh
also is a degree of
since you want some positivity
um some production Equity between
content creators versus needing a studio
or a network to reach the people right
because up until now up until YouTube
you needed someone else to get to where
you are to sell the theater show someone
else had to tell you yes yeah now even
though there's an algorithm to navigate
you can learn the algorithm you learn
how to hack it you learn how to get
yeah to the [__] people directly so
if we're gonna start doing more CGI
we're going to start doing more AI most
of the cameras that content creators use
now are neck and neck with what they're
using in television yeah so if that's
the case and things are going to get
more techy and AI well if the studio is
using AI to write a script well [__] so
can I right right exactly and so we're
using the same [__] apps or whatever
it's not like your AI is better than my
[__] AI yeah so I think that there's
going to be some degree of levity
in the world for our for our craft
because I'm just thinking how do I keep
doing this outside of just being on
stage 40 weeks a year right because as
my son gets older I want to cut that to
20. yeah you know like if I'm only
touring let's say let's say right right
now and this is the type of [__] I have
to think about now let's say Daily Show
don't [__] with me they're already doing
that midnight in the place according so
that's not an option so the only other
thing is to try and sell my own
independent show if those things those
things shows come and go I've sold
scripts that have gone some haven't but
the stage Remains the Same so if I'm on
stage then what are the other things
that I can do that I can control in
terms of content creation that animation
[__] I think that's going to be like
what you're talking about where they
just have a full digital
type movie or whatever
I think people are going to have to
start learning that [__] and then yeah
like you got I mean they had a they had
a commercial during the Super Bowl a
couple weeks ago but that site to be oh
we talked about it yeah 2B is putting a
lot of independent [__] on a lot some of
it is shot poorly and it's terrible
lighting and you need a [__] budget
to get a second like but
it's fair right that's that's fair right
free market right so if you can find
your audience in any type of way you
don't have to necessarily lean on a show
you know what I'm saying yeah right okay
that's why we encourage you guys to go
to onlyfans.com hey babe where Sal and I
are doing a show there that um is a
little bit different it's a little
different it's a little different it's
it goes against what you know of us yeah
or maybe it Embraces is it cooking no
cooking yeah yeah butt naked
um there's just one one episode is just
the camera Pimp's got the camera on mine
and Sal's open [__] the whole time
that is nice
it's nice nice and clean it's it's it's
it's it's not it's a departure it is a
departure well Walt Roy since since uh
the AI isn't here yet since we haven't
gotten the official word on The Daily
Show where can people see you next yes
and except for the snitch [__] yeah
except for that snitch Fiat [__]
snitch
[__] you know who you are yeah no we
don't but you know that's enough yeah I
know who it is all you had to do was
come to me like a [__] man after the
show and go hey there's another comedian
with a similar thought but you didn't do
that did you because you like drama
that's right
and now snitch [__] these dates are not
for you okay these dates are not fair
for the people who want to go work [__]
what do I have left at this point uh I'm
in Arizona uh stand up blood I don't
[__] oh stand up live good I think
it's stand up live it might be Tempe
Improv I don't just go to Just Google
Roy with the desert yeah just run with
Junior put an ad in front put a.com
behind it you'll find the rest of the
dates um I got a bunch of tour dates
this summer hitching bits against the
writers strike boys
[Laughter]
this summer
all right baby
christycomedy.com salvocanocomedy.com
and uh that's it babe rorywood junior
thank you for joining us the great Roy
Wood Junior thank you boys appreciate it
this has been hey babe this has been hey
babe snitch [__]
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey
[Music]